welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on the epigenome
in health and disease it's my pleasure
to introduce to you dr. Michael Snyder
who is the Stanford a Sherman professor
and chair of genetics and the director
of the Center for genomics and
personalized medicine at Stanford
University School of Medicine dr. Snyder
is a leader in the field of functional
genomics and proteomics and one of the
major participants of the encode project
his laboratory study was the first to
perform a large-scale functional
genomics project in any organism and has
developed many technologies in genomics
and proteomics they have been used for
characterizing genomes proteomes and
regulatory networks dr. Snyder is the
author of the book genomics and
personalized medicine for complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. Snyder's keynote presentation is
titled big data and health my name is
Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Snyder I will
now turn the presentation over to him ok
well thanks very much for having me here
it's really a pleasure do cause a
network to you I do have a number of
conflicts they're all listed at the
bottom of the slide so I'm going to
serve as a premise that many of you may
not like to hear but it's really that
the way we do medicine these days is all
wrong
this isn't fact aside from Stephen
Hubbell that well actually sorry it's
the next slide and that presents that
but this is the way we do medicine is on
the Left which is that we're presently
very focused on treating people when
were when they're ill as such is very
reactive we measure very very few things
the frequency we measured people when
their health is you usually rather rare
and in general nearly all decisions
based on medicine are based on
population based or measurements the
contrast I think multiplets would agree
we should really be focused on health
and it's let's be very proactive for
capable of measuring many many more
things than we measure in boxes office
the frequency I will argue should depend
on what you're at risk for and your
health trajectories for those sigmoid
areas that you aren't highest with and
lastly I think all of us would agree
that medicine should be based on the
individual not based on population based
measurement and so we should really be
focused on precision health rather than
precision medicine so to illustrate this
point this is a slide I've gotten from
Steve ensign Hubble which is it's
probably many of you think that you're
actually the standard temperature when
you take the oil temperature is 98.6
that's what we're normally taught and it
turns out though if you actually do a
study like the one shown here that
several them out there like this it's
one it's measured 3,000 people it turns
out first well that number is wrong the
median number is not nineteen point six
but in fact ninety seven point five is
probably a lot more accurate and not
only that if you look at the this box at
the bottom of the box that's a
twenty-fifth quartile and the number is
ninety four points to explore the 75th
quartile that's top of the box that's
ninety nine point one
so the point is that there's actually a
spread and this is a people Southie
baseline state it's what it means is
that people have went world temperatures
it's of your normal oral temperature is
ninety four point six and you go to a
doctor today you walk in the office and
you come in at 98.6 they'll tell you
you're perfectly healthy everything's
fine you're in great shape what are you
doing you go home when in contrast
you're really up four degrees of your
baseline measurement you're probably
rather sick and you would never capture
that because you didn't know the
baseline measurement so the point is
these population-based measure decisions
are not always in your best interest so
we think again will steam off the glint
many time we think it's very very
important that you understand what your
baseline values are and then you can
find deviations for that to better
capture your illness so the health state
if you will depends upon many things and
depends upon your DNA isn't sure mostly
appreciate but it depends upon other
things such as exposures shown on the
bottom left as well as lifestyle your
exercise the food you eat the various
activities you do all contribute to your
health state I mean I envision a world
where in the not so distant future
people will be born with the genome
already sequence and then you'd like to
understand what kinds of activities what
kinds of things you do will influence
your health in some probabilistic
fashion what is the safe you're at risk
for Parkinson's you may not want to be a
pesticide worker because that greatly
increases your chances of getting
Parkinson's so we think it's very very
important that you have the relevant
information available so that you can
adjust your lifestyle accordingly so as
many of you probably appreciate there's
now a revolution in being able to
collect data that we think will impact
your health the one that gets the most
attention is the top one shown here
which is genome sequencing you can now
get your genome sequence for $1000 or
less the interpretation we will argue as
costs much more at least to go out very
thoroughly the way we draw but
nonetheless you can get your genome
sequenced around there
thousand dollars and in the future that
never will become much much cheaper evil
well we would argue there's been equally
strong revolution going on in mass
spectrometry stick an amateur many
thousands of proteins and metabolites in
bodily fluids like blood and urine and
so you're capable of getting a much much
better molecular picture on people using
for these tools and more recently we
would argue there's been a revolution in
the wearable technology so you can
actually get continuous measurements off
with people and so in fact we use all of
these different technologies and others
to be able to better capture information
that we think is relevant for people's
health so as many of you may know a
number of years ago we set up something
we call personal omics profiling where
it's most deluxe forms we measure
people's genomes we do that once but
then we measure other ohms than its most
deluxe form we measure about 13 other
omics measurements in the gold scenario
that was probably measuring eight other
realms on people
we follow them over time so this is a
project started about nine years ago a
little over nine years ago now that
she's setting me and now we've been
running it for over six years on a
hundred seven auto people and in
collecting just lots and lots of data
and specifically to you down from the
genome you'll see epigenome that means a
DNA methyl on we measure transcriptome
most of this is off of blood components
specifically peripheral blood monocyte
cells these are your immune cells so
we'll measure the transcriptome pretty
and we measure off those cells in plasma
when this is with swim-team t labeling
and mass spectrometry you also have
immunoassays for following 63 cytokines
and growth factors the last five or six
years now we've been optimizing both the
tab limits and what padam likes to be
able to get much much deeper profiles
there all the way antibodies and then
we've also been doing mostly two
different microbiomes got nasal then we
collect samples for launching others
this is on top of making clinical
testing we had questionnaires and we
have a lot of glucose measurements
you'll see in a bit is our cohort
insurance I was Richard
risk for type 2 diabetes about half of
them are either pre-diabetic the blind
better well and then we also have we
look over the left we have wearables we
started that about six years ago as well
but so in general what we do is we
sample people quarterly so every three
months or so when they're healthy and
there's an adverse event comes along
like a viral infection will take many
more samples typically about five more
samples and then other events as well
that we will actually measure people for
example they have a polonaise P will
most them before and after and we have a
lot of different kinds of food and
perturbations other sorts of sightings
ringing as well so again we've been
running this little slide a little bit
out of eight but it's four for six years
for most people Sun a little bit more
Sun a little bit less but so we're
collecting all kinds of deep data so why
are we doing this what we're really
trying to understand what it needs to be
healthy mostly is individual are healthy
say so fair number of pre diabetic could
go a lot of the us bubble right but
we're trying to understand what it means
to be healthy how does that differ among
people how does it change over time but
what happens when people undergo some of
these perturbations like a viral
function insults but what does that mean
for their health what exactly is going
wrong so as you might imagine when you
carry out a study like this you've
really an extraordinary amount of data
it's unbelievable well by the way most
of the data is I can publicly available
not all but the vast majority of folks
who agreed to make their data including
their genome sequences open access so
all of you can get access to it except
microbiome or website if you will for
the data coordinating Center where all
those data reside so we've clicked a ton
of data and we actually have all kinds
of very interesting stories around with
but what I'll tell you over the next 30
40 minutes or so are some of the
vignettes of interesting findings we
have so it turns out from the gene I'm
alone we find quite a few and
interesting results like this from the
first seventy people we had 12
individuals who have clinically
actionable information that is to say
there be teachings in their DNA they
should know about that will actually
thank their health care and on
this one in any year poly familiar if
this is bought one at the bottom of the
list called brocco we had one individual
with a pack one mutation which could
cite individual higher risk for breast
cancer others here as well if you go up
number four from the list that are be in
twenty one individual has our being our
BM twenty mutation pretty young person
and it turns out that that predicts a
mutation and leaves a party mouth being
sure enough it turns out this individual
has cardiomyopathy
big companies when stress I'd go after
getting genome sequence so it's pretty
clear and back there on drugs now so
it's very clear that some of the dual
finding this we teach and very important
for the health she loved her father and
antiparticles following two died young
one is heart attack so the point is
these can be very very important pieces
of information so now I'll just give you
another example if you look third one
down agent F 1 alpha that actually is in
an individual ninety very folks are
actually thought to be type two diabetic
when they enroll it turns out this
individual who it was classified as
thank you diabetic was not tied to at
all they're different kind of diabetics
from Modi and they've been on the wrong
medication for years so they're actually
shifting the medication as a consequence
of this information because the way you
treat a motor pool so very different
from the coke bottle well at the very
top unless we had one in two individuals
two X means we had H s P D mutations and
one of the individuals had a whole body
MRI and turns out had early thyroid
cancer which can be associated with
mutations in the scheme looks like she
she had that part we knew then was able
to then maintain another half of a
thyroid which doesn't mean to go on
thyroid replacement hormone so the
bottom line is many people had useful
information from the genome sequence
alone it's not the majority it's twelve
out of 70 but if you're one of those
twelve it's a pretty big deal now where
recently we've come up with new ways of
analyzing genome shown here when we're
we come up
in this case for abdominal aortic
aneurysm so generally when people are
analyzed complex on disease what they do
is they try to find all these comments
nets when add them up these days people
out of millions of snaps to try and
predict disease risk and that works for
people at the far end of the spectrum
the problem is it's very hard to work
may not work so well other parts because
we think that genetics is not very
linear you can't just add up things one
plus one doesn't always equal to in the
case of genetics if they're in the same
pathway one plus one equals one and if
they're synergistic one plus one equal
four
so the point is you can't just add up
genetic variants and expect phenotypes
to point out in a linear fashion so we
actually decide to take a different tact
for looking at complex disease which is
looking at rare variants which is not
normally done it's only just done for
Mendelian disease we decide to try this
for a particular disease abdominal
aortic aneurysm it's just kind of a big
deal it affects if you're 65 years or
older about 10% of people like you get
this and too big label dials in a minute
and it's even overall in the population
which is relatively prevalent the
problem with that is that with abdominal
area can use and the way she usually
discovered is people of a aorta grows
and then it bursts and they die and
that's typically how and you're found to
have this disease so it has a 90%
mortality rate so obviously getting an
early critical test would be a very very
big deal so the new approach we used was
around look at common variants we said
can we look at rare variants and set up
predicted path from both so the genetic
underpinnings of this disease are not
very well known at all just a few genes
and them inculcated it really isn't
known what the genetic architecture is
and so we set out we sequenced 401
genomes excuse me to high-quality 268 or
cases of work to the left and 133 of
controls well these are whole genome
sequences when we
sequencer dental about 60 accent
elliptical top we then called ran
looking for common variants we looked
for pathogenic and likely pathogenic
variants we called that throughout the
genome and then we did a machine
learning algorithm with the 10-fold
cross-validation four sets of genes we
didn't say how many we just say give a
set some teams that would be
hypermutated the qisas relative to
controls and even though it's only 401
genes with this approach the machine
learning actually picked out 60 genes
they were hyper enrichment cases
relative to controls and his clinical a
little very very strong people 10-13 and
so it's a very very robust set of genes
which seem to be enriched in case
relatively controlled and then we went
on a validating this by many means we
went out and got the mouse orthologues
and these and sure enough they tend to
be written in heart issues we actually
could assemble modules around these
games so these are the interacting
partners of these 60 teams if you will
then look at the pathways involved it's
all the things you would expect one
circulation blood pressure claim apathy
aneurysms another module and so on so
these are exactly the sorts of genes
there miss regulated both in humans that
have AAA as well as in mouse models they
so again it seems to be the sorts of
genes you would would expect to be
involved in this disease finally we
could go on and actually set up a
predictive test for the disease that
shown here where from the genome alone
you do okay just from a genome sequence
that's this red line on the right you
can actually make a pretty good vessel
about points that them so it's not
perfect but it's okay
just from genome sequence alone
predicting risk for disease from these
60 teams if you add in a little bit of
EHR data and basically what you'll find
is so you can see that light savings on
things here at Stanford so the dark a
moment there anyway if you add take the
genome sequence at a
little bit of other clinical information
you will in fact improve the prediction
quite a bit you'll get it up to about
point eight and it looks modest on the
EHR adding up that over each arc was
phenom what's modest over EHR alone but
actually greatly decreases the false
negative rate quite a bit so the bottom
line out of all this is that with with
the genome sequence we can now set up a
predictive test for disease that was
normally discovered when someone like he
dies and so see how it compares with
other tasks we chose here these are all
the clinical tasks that that we had out
there where I could find and basically
from the genome alone it's okay it's
that blue squared where this is a
predictive values with specificity and
sensitivity but if you look at it from
the genome post EHR it's a pretty decent
class and it's as good as or better than
many other tests they're up there now
and what's nice about it is it's
actionable information if you're a
high-risk you should actually elevate
your your HDL and that will dramatically
lower your risk being show that another
Studies on failure so the bottom line
out out of all this is by this new
genome analysis approach we can find
ways in which to predict we put risk for
a complex and fatal disease that didn't
exist before we do it now but some
predictive value right from birth but
even better after a few clinical
measurements that's just one of the
kinds of stories with an equal study
overall turns out by profiling this
group of 107 people or from about the
first four years of data we had 49 made
here helped discovery so by doing big
data analysis we had 49 major health
discoveries that you found with this
approach that you're not find by normal
visiting the Vaqueros office kinds of
things either again things that came out
of our big data analysis so I mentioned
12 from the genome but there are lots of
other things as well and I'm going to
show you a few examples in a minute so
when Pharma we count one piece of early
lymphoma that's in the bottom area so
the major
categories we bump them into a metabolic
cardiovascular hematology infectious and
on a variety of others so as I say we in
the he mock we had wonderful pearly
lymphoma to people with pre-cancer one
called n Gus I'll show you that in a
minute mother was smoldering myeloma
finding these is a big deal she's with
people I on them we had in addition the
one person with a heart defect I
mentioned earlier there's a second
person who had a significant heart issue
turnout that was to sleep apnea so that
we believe is now under control and
there's a variety of other things as
well I'll walk you through a few
examples right now so this next slide
shows an example of some of the early
lymphoma but this is picked up by
imaging so by actually doing ultrasound
they were doing half of our groups and
stress like oh this individual did as
well natural traceur they image the
spleen at the same time let's just had a
one person so yeah I had in the large
spleen they had other elevated markers
in their blood as well
and sure enough it turns out they had
early lymphoma which was taught what was
kind of interesting is in retrospect we
can find a marker that made a lot of
sense and so this graph at the bottom
the peak is actually when we detected
their enlarged spleen and then they
retreated there then went remission
right away you can see that the lines
are went down but there's a very
interesting marker shown here that
actually tracks with the onset of this
disease and makes sense so we have a
possible new marker for the pharma that
that didn't exist before
another example is channel in this next
slide this is an individual that
actually was found from outlier analysis
so there's a thousand data points here
one individual who had been sampled
twice at that point these two data
points also fairly young person had way
too many ideas over what you expect
everybody else is in that bunch down at
the bottom and this individual just has
a ton more IgM cells and more IgM than
anyone else in the bunch so it's pretty
and then went on and had a formal
diagnosis
when Gauss and since 15% of NGOs folks
why not going on and becoming getting
aggressive cancer finding this out now
some big deal because you could actually
then model more closely and catch them
if they would do turn their aggressive
cancel we might even need things you can
do that you want produced canceled or a
better treatment by preparing for it now
than waiting together we six people
actually had plaque somewhere arteries
I'm one of the folks you're hearing
fever any red arrows was just a little
bit of plaque in the artery in all six
cases was it now too close to the mean
and in all six they had a recommendation
of increased statins or true for me and
my plaque is not actually shrinking or
the law as a consequence we're doing
more as I mentioned before a lot of
people there's a lot of interest in type
two diabetes for the study well that
simply because when actually take two
diabetics in my case it was critical for
my genome which and then we also his
later on a minute
well we were enrolling people right
either at risk a lot of them were just
plain old normal folks be enriched as
well and going into the study on the
Left bar is what people thought they had
there were nine individuals that thought
that would take two diabetic a few that
thought they would take pre-diabetic
that's not right rgeous bar and it turns
out it's studying wrong when two people
are diabetic two didn't even know it so
we discovered that right away a ton of
people are pre-diabetic and didn't know
I turned out nine out of ten three
diabetics won't know they're partly well
then during the course of the study
others either had diabetic values that
were formally classified as well about
21 other people I diabetic range
measurements nine individuals became
formally diagnosed goodbye Jews and one
of them when I'm not for them one of
them I she lost weight it's helped so
what was interesting to us was how do
people become diabetic do they gradually
work their way in do they spike in
whether some of the underlying
ways which people get diagnosed or what
are some of the underlying mechanisms
provide with people at volleyball
well turns out people get diabetic in
different ways and that's shown here
this top one that's like to me that's
about where I'm seven or eight years of
data actually there then ways to other
people it doesn't say we had nine people
came down both to people spiked their
way into diabetic and I'm one of those
two so if you look here the orange line
is fasting glucose okay so top left
panel punchline fasting glucose the gray
line is through of an a1c and I actually
was going along just fine at first bite
to the left side into into diabetic
range measurements after an antiviral
that's actually not a mini spike that's
eight months of data from Peter 10 and I
went up by both fasting glucose in the
world I don't see energy to tea I don't
know the controlling this year with
lifestyle but if they spiked back again
later and that's fine I never ever
really got it down drifting up got
higher it's a little complicated it's
not running which is about the time I
first like aside the seconds jump up
there well and then it when it got
pretty high then I discovered it was
high again I'm also running Bella summer
lower anyway I'm back to take the ball
better there's one other person let's
fight the way into diabolic way most
people just gradually became diabetic so
we slowly slowly became type two
diabetic over time and and they got
there by different measurement for one
at the bottom was measured that make
suppose something called oral glucose
tolerance test the one in the middle of
my fasting glucose is like hemoglobin
a1c so it does seem like there's
heterogeneity when white people are both
fighting house in the way they became
diabetic two individuals by the way seem
that associated IV
became diabetic in the judge with our
large waiting and then the others
actually became would did not became
diabetic without a waiting so
so most people became diabetic without
gaining weight and fall and so so again
when the underlying causes of area
and it turns out the way they are
diabetic was also very very different if
you can see here we measured Rachel
insulin secretion and kind of other
measurements on people resistance and so
on and so forth and you can see
different people the top guys are people
who secrete insulin or Mele pretty
quickly after taking glucose others are
more more delay the ones at the bottom
are quite delayed and what we found
there's just enormous heterogeneity in
people in the way people are diabetic in
the way they have this regulation and
I'm doing a slab I am NOT a normal type
2 diabetic most normal take most type 2
diabetics actually insulin sensitive in
my case one person most type 2 diabetics
in some system actually happened to
being insulin sensitive I Nathan's from
just fine I'm actually for joy relief so
I'm one of the people at the bottom and
so in fact the way I should be treated -
thank you guys very different thing I
was personal I don't respond to my
Foreman well I probably should think
increase seeker guards which actually
come out of sedation so the point out of
all this is that there's many many ways
in which people can have glucose
dysregulation and understanding the
underlying mechanisms is going to be
very very valuable with the treating
them now another area well that we've
looked at is in fact in a methylation so
many of you may appreciate that DNA
methylation is associated with with
lifestyle and other other sorts of
things and so it's thought that your
nutrition exercise aging the environment
can all affect cleaning methylation this
is a sheet by both epigenomics now DNA
methylation is associated with gene
silencing so if we methylated your genes
are methylated in the promoter in
general they're usually shut off or
reduce them expression and so there's a
lot of interest in trying to follow DNA
methylation because it can be
potentially it's another way in which we
have gene regulation and it's one
affected by ways
which you have some control again with
food and exercise although how this
whole thing works I should emphasize is
not really understood at all and it is
also interesting your methylome changes
with age so we actually decided to go
and look at for me and a few others what
happens with methylation over time and
so we actually my teeth measured my gene
of my methylation throughout the genome
using something called a whole genome
bisulfite sequencing so to measure all
of my methylated bases if you are sees
the CPGs in particular tend to be
methylated when we did this time for the
first 3 plus years of my measurements
that we take to now bring us fine first
3 years was in the study in three and a
quarter years I had been through six
viral infections are all shown here
they're all common colds yellow is Rhino
virus a problem red is respiratory
syncytial eyes that's a rare case and
the two blue ones towards the bottom are
analyzed emotion again all very common
colds during this time I hadn't taken 57
samplings if you will so we decided we
would follow both my my RNA my
transcript Tom as well as my DNA methyl
arm across the spine period and so we
did transcript them at all 57 fine
points the methyl one we did 28 and we
did last is a very very expensive
experiment actually hopefully almost all
fight sequence we did 28 so he did the
viral infections and then we did several
the hobby time competing through them
all then for cost and what we discovered
is this first part is not a surprise
what we discovered is that the
transcriptome
changed a lot every time I had a viral
infection so during each of these six
viral infections you look at the left
panel each of those colored boxes is a
viral infection period when it starts at
the beginning of the period so those
plantains of the bunch they each row is
a different King these pounds a
different fine point and what you'll see
is that there were many many changes
during each of these viral infections
that's not a surprise
if you look at the genes of change we
look at the categories that's shown on
the right it's your immune response team
that we're changing every time you get a
viral infection yeah that's not a big
surprise what was really tall as the
next slide shown here was even though my
RNA was changing every viral faction my
eating methyl um only changed twice the
exact same population of cells that were
mentioned there two times they change by
the two times when my glucose went off
so you see those little dots it's
probably hard to see there at the end of
the red box and there's another set that
starts appearing at the end of the last
yellow box it's at the top of the left
panel if you look at those little dots
there so I can't point this out to you
but that's when my glucose is elevated
it's the same plot I'll show you earlier
and what you'll see is that my DNA
methyl aam action changes each row is is
well I'll say a region of the genome
that showing changes and this happens to
be reading from promoters and what
you'll see is that there - if you will
radish regions now these are huge
changes there are several percent but
they do go off and it typically precedes
when the glucose Peaks actually so we
think these are early events sites now
60 to 90 days before the glucose piece
or hits and speeds values and again it
happens each time a glucose went off and
furthermore if you actually look at the
types of genes where these promoters are
sitting next to do that your metabolic
UHN for their action signs the French or
regulations we go analysis your
metabolic team actually showing
differential DNA methylation
yeah growing these lines when you're
good closest is regulating in fact main
engines aren't like the lava grupos
population so what we think is happening
is that your your methyl arm is a
measure if you will chronic disease
whereas your transcript um as a measure
of acute disease and that makes a lot of
sense from methylation changes are
probable not quite
maybe were permanent in nature in the
sense that if you mean out aging is a
permanent response here the methylome
changes with age so again we think here
your methylation is measuring chronic
disease situations while as opposed to
acute disease another very important
finding it was flooding is that everyone
is go home so no matter what home we use
people will cluster by themselves not by
a condition when I'll just show you
these are the healthy plant points but
make sure you even if I sprinkle them
the disease like now keep it simple this
is 12 people because that leaves 10
healthy baseline visit so a lot of those
it's over several years I happen to be
the one it being lately so I'm a part of
this study and you'll see that each
color is a sampling he started there in
sampling he needs colors from a
different person it's like people well
clustered these how thing is like this
is six years of data for me it was light
blue and they all cluster according to
me and same is cheery for the brown
radish each color again is a blue in
person so really need clinical labs
cytokines but I'm not so much for the
transcriptome stuff for all the other
wrong very very strongly clustered by
themselves and so what that means is
that your personal signatures are really
quite robust that doesn't say you're
very different than the person sitting
next to you and in fact that turns out
to be for the most part greater even if
you get sick or something else that
needs to say people with viral illnesses
or or we get a weight gain weight loss
study they will you will shift if you
gain weight but you will still look more
like you than anyone else so your
personal signature we think they're
really really robust in fact if you
really get off your feet but the end of
the presentation when someone took a
swab in pencil off they had the right
reference they can tell is you use that
though because you'd be leaving wine the
very robust signature so you
these we arguing these personal
signatures but to me this is the real
reason why you need to do personalized
medicine both lifestyle in individual
level after their peoples baseline so
you can see the difference between the
first one their ill relative the healthy
it's hard to tell someone who's getting
ill relative does everyone else everyone
else healthy management you have to know
your difference relative to your healthy
baseline so the other area that we've
been spending a lot of time on lately is
with this wearable technology so this is
really a say chemo a number of years ago
mostly just for activity tracking
fitness things like that we wanted to
see starting about six years ago whether
we can use these as people have
measurements as well and so these days
believe or not they're 900 these
portable sensors on the market
smartwatches attention so we went out
we've cut something out about 30 or 40
of these over the years the big issue is
getting access to the data and so we
actually is saying testimony of them at
the end of the day we settled on eight
or nine of them aware every day in fact
them yeah maybe you can't see this but
I'm wearing three smartwatches this rain
is not going ring it's a sensor so there
are these portable devices that like you
take all kinds of measurements and as I
say we're eight or nine the rest of it
go where it usually uses an apple most
my smartphone along with a SmartWatch
that we put that one so again these
things these these devices they make all
kinds of measuring for measuring your
activity will make your heart rates in
temperature feed their devices imagine
brought oxygen rating radiation monitors
or make we're cell steps etc so we
measure many many different things and
what's powerful about these devices as
they measure them continuously so single
SmartWatch will make about twenty fifty
thousand measurements away the likes one
to make many many more so we're getting
a lot of data in real time so we view
these drug like tracking all kinds of
things we can set up and figure out
people's personal baseline crime where
for example
circadian patterns about heart rates
things I'm sure will be quite all that
data and then what you try and do is
actually find evh and some people
regular patterns and maybe a few
vignettes here one of the biggest
deviations for me for my baseline is
actually when I fly turns out this is no
no rating look at you your blood oxygen
will drop in airplanes it's known it's
that you're not well know most flight
attendants don't Morton a lot of pilots
don't know but basically when the left
is a panel that shows a flight from San
Francisco to San Diego Green is altitude
so the plane goes nothing comes down
then glue as my blood oxygen look starts
at around this is I think about nine
seven drugs down so lower for the sure
flight then she comes back up on land
and that's true I'm pretty much every
single flight I think on Sinai true for
me we've now measured somewhere around
eighty different people everybody with
one exception everybody's blood oxygen
drops on aircraft well it turns out I
won't show you beautiful it's but it
correlates with fatigue so in fact we
think the reason you're getting tired on
our path is because we drop the air
pressure on the plane and well your your
blood oxygen get tired and some people
drops a lot more than Threadless might
be about five percent I will be mine
year below and then multiplying it runs
around one two three some people need to
be loyal what was powerful is that we
actually found these kinds of
measurements are very useful for sure
when people get ill and I actually
figured out my Lyme disease I'm a pulse
ox and from my SmartWatch and so the
back story behind this before I did you
mentioned David Baxter in behind this is
I something my brother put up fences in
rural Massachusetts then two weeks later
I strike tomorrow way through Frankel
and so on this last flight from
Frankfurt Castle which is a pretty low
aircraft your blood oxygen does not
normally drop too much or more than
green for left hand panel and green is
what my blood
normally does when a short flight of
what sort and blue is what happened on
this but you look like my median value
for look in the middle actuaries and was
about nine it's a pretty low for reading
value turns out and then when I land it
if you put the last slide of that panel
turns out when I landed my blood auction
stated ninety-five then come back up to
normal which is supposed to hold this
hat so the bottom line had a whole this
is that my blood auctions abnormally low
and we do my heart rate it's not trying
here high resolution but go up the right
panel this is daily averages which we
will outline measurements to be precise
then what we know this was at the time
my heart rate was up later I let my most
in temperatures off to so the bottom
line out of this is that high rate skin
temperature and blood auction when were
off and it turns out that when right
after that I get a low-grade fever I did
after several days went to a doctor in
Norway and I warned him ahead of time
making Lyme disease to the timing of two
weeks and you're little suspicious and I
do not get a bull's-eye by the way and
he actually lied they're in their way
and they said they were up and said yet
we've got a bacterial infection I know
you should take penicillin well my
hunches so now I think it can take
doctor actually cycle as you might
imagine we got tensed or a few moments
there
he didn't give in gave me eight weeks
five black things like where we take
trunk and including it right up and so
within 24 hours I was right back to
normal and when I got back that's that
positive sign on the right panel it's
your blood and it was measured sure
enough I was lying positive and it turns
out I'd given blood before I left from
Norway serendipitously so it turns out I
was lying negative and tested that one
then so the point is I had C converted
during that time and the net reason the
bottom line is that I was able figure
out my Lyme disease by an emerald drop
of blood oxygen an elevated heart rate
so we we can detect the pretty serious
disease just from these simple devices
well that prompted us when we deal with
a need for
now all the data I had at that time so I
drew yours the data from the smart walls
when we looked at if you look at the
left we look at outline matches just an
abbreviation two more this is contempt
jungle at the bottom is sorry it's a
little mess up there but blood psyche
you out lying heart rate and it turned
out over these two years were four times
when I had high seer peel is probably
all three times where we were being
symptomatic and so there's Lyme disease
case that's a triangle days these are
daily on poverty there are two viral
disease the top one and actually that
bottom high co2 and there's a fourth
time where I didn't report the yell but
I had high CB same levels as being you
know probably successfully for a lot and
the cool result was that every single
time at elevated CRP and high outlying
heart rate and things on every single
talk so that yes you right so we wrote
an algorithm we call it change of heart
that detects the earliest times when you
get ill by elevated heart rate every
arresting background and it works really
quite well on my four times to get ill
we test the wrong
three other people one who got ill twice
every single time we can see the change
in heart rate over resting background
well before people reported bring
something out so we think this is an
early measure of illness again before
you symptomatic the worst case between
shell but the primary is starting to
feel a little congested but we actually
think it shows up before long cuz we're
now rolling salads a thousand person
study or you can roll with it well smart
watch I should point out spin temp
shouldn't work very well for us I mean
cuz not only were there there watch
tighten out heart rate works very well
though so that's what we're testing and
so the goal will be to tell people when
they're getting sick before he realizes
we think I have more on a value another
area that
you have to be very very impactful is
for wearables is glucose dysregulation
so I mentioned before that nine out of
10 pre-diabetic have no idea to feed I
thought well these days are the simple
glucose monitoring to come well right
now you require a physician though in
Europe and probably at some point you
actually able to get them without for
physicians prescription so we put these
on normal and pre-diabetic on on a few
diabetic dog to see what there's 18
calling and it turns out we solve
different kinds of patterns as shown
here top line shows an individual's
glucose control doesn't spike months and
24 hours next guys like some I'm like
prison spiking a lot to pretty high
levels so we basically written
algorithms to be able more
systematically classified people and we
classified them into what we call [ __ ]
it takes the idea everything can be
tossed and that we can go through and
actually picked out basically we go into
these these glucose management's me pick
out the paddles is something called
spectral clustering and then we can
classify the patterns and the percent of
time to bring these patterns and each
row here is a different person on the
right side so you chose the one person
wanted the bottom these are people with
a row spiking you can play ones in the
middle or the the moderate spiking one's
a talk with severe spike and wellness to
be respected more today because I think
a lot so he boasted what people on
standardized meals and one I'm tend to
go into this but some people will spend
more on bread and peanut butter
others on 13 Mars and so on and so forth
people will spike to the conference and
Aaron T oils live is moister sham the
microbiome is an important part a lot
one agency observation we have is that
nearly everybody spikes of cornflakes
milk this is like poison even argue well
it's probably worse a lot more all the
way there bait spike means poor things
and more we think well small to go
through so we now so then look at again
I mentioned we put these are normal
people we dyed eggs and so on so there
were left-hand panel just shows
classifying people
why they're spiking pattern so so those
pinkish red means your your severe spike
there reminds like the means here on
control inspect notes wrong and what we
can find is that people we've classified
all these people by fasting because he
Roman able ta GTT but we find people
like ease to it with the arrows plenty
of them that are severe spider but by
all normal diabetic measurements
actually look normal they don't show any
sign of classical equals problems
hemoglobin a1c or obesity problems but
yet they're slightly just as much as
diabetics so we think there are people
running around there with some pretty
severe glucose just regulations we have
no idea what would even get missed by
common asses so we think these delays to
will only be very very powerful their
diagnosis new post this regulation so
the last thing I want to tell you is an
area that I feel like we've never been
able to get at very well so we spent a
lot of time on this this is your
exposures so we're very interested in
trying to understand what is your
exposure and a person alive on and we
excited system starting to work on
airborne exposure school yeah we all
breathe when we stopping things all the
time and I guarantee probably one of you
right now on their work exactly
breathing phenomenal we get it might be
it might be bad for you just have no
idea so we important asthma well it's
like chemicals it's very important for
Texas uh being canceled and so on so we
think it's very very important to
measure all these things and if you
think about a lot of basics about giving
expose room just is not known so for
example we don't know maybe the expose
them usually ten species or thousand
species no and chemical same thing
getting expose pretty much the same
thing was a very lot from place to place
where's the more seasonal effects we
know where they are given exposure was
coming from now does the chemical and
biological spoken for and so on so the
bottom line is was that um we basically
set up a method for following
foreclosures so we actually took a near
minor and it's a small device it's like
sit there and then we modified it as a
pump that sucks one about one fifteenth
of what you breathe and under the intact
we actually have a particular we measure
it catches all the particles biologicals
and in it inert things and then
underneath that we have our clinical
absorbent on the cartridge with
chemicals urban and so for the
biological is what we do is we'll take
the filter we actually harvest DNA RNA
sequence incredibly deeply for the
chemicals we actually take ten to absorb
and balloon off the chemicals and do
math which on each a measure many
clinicals as possible so we're usually
very high level technologies to see
what's an example and then we follow
people over time and so on a typical
scenario probably the device for
typically once one device during the
week one on the weekend and every time I
go to me what came from Boston trying or
whatever I'll take it over blight to
make separate measurement so we can
follow a location we can follow we
tweevils the weekend mentions the Third
Point and we've now profile or something
that was here before but basically ate
all the color is evaporated sorry about
flat and the bottom line is that you
can't lead with legging wearing I'm T
one mental when we all come almost all
didn't sleep before but he one is me and
we've I've been wearing the device for
now will be six years of summer we've
collected two years of data that we've
analyzed initially
40 p2 is actually awarding the device
for a year p3 a little over three months
and then we have up to 17 other people
warned under one circumstance I'll
explain for Martin and win it and you
can't see on the right side but I travel
all over the world we have tons of
measurements from all over the planet so
we can see the exposure will find
different locations also little teeth
and so on
turns out p3 travel for when you ask
quite a bit way from there to three
months not too tall like that okay so
bottom line is we can make all these
measurements and so we've sequential
ridiculously deep amount of reads and
title we've done over 70 billion reads
and trillion base pairs and and look at
these results from about 40 billion of
reads of DNA 30 from RNA 1 so it's quite
thank you and so I'm totally measured
over 25 minutes
he's was simply about 300 species per
sampling even the person wearing the
expose ometer for 3 months had over a
thousand species so so conclusion number
one is that the exposed I was last you
will get exposed many different species
just by walking around breathing and so
on yeah we did a little bit of
validation spin-1 how dynamic is that
well this is one year between months and
basically each color represents a
different Kingdom so red is bacteria was
banished when you're suppose I'm sorry
green of course the plants and blue are
animals and so what you'll notice just
look at me on the timeline at the top as
you look at across time zones piping and
if it depends now from weed we caught
each location within with more detail
same is true for piercings 3 bottom
we've busted these you can see the left
sides mostly plant exposure days when
that's multi-run culture well sir action
fun relaxed on jewels though last bikes
make some what's true for me complete
green song so a lot of mine
we will have disposals video sample
materials so the next question what's
driving your dynamic expose them and the
answer is instantly though all a lot
work locations and seasons and so the
leftist shows my samples and for the
role the PCA when kind of plot if you
will you'll notice of the asian samples
with a reddish one is on the left side
there during that ready circle so
they're more on one type of sam or among
other locations for others and the same
is true for season we can see some
effects there and when you quantify this
as to what's kinda cool so for dialogue
box dollars you mean quantify how much
we can assign we can't assign most cliff
divers so trying to figure out where
it's coming from right my boss is very
very specific rotation though the bottom
line is we can say for what we can
assign or what is the location but
here's now environmental which is mostly
season i change another big player and
some of us even take the barn [ __ ] so
with that in mind we actually got a
whole bunch of fog studies to follow
location i'll just say one of these okay
this control
so this was actually a very defined
experiment test about the locations we
found four people over the exact same
month with these expose ominous and the
one in purple lives in San Francisco
the red one here that light blue person
lives and works across today but soon it
was pretty close to me it works closely
means the green one there it's not my
standing switch our priest Ballard same
with the light blue they're a little
more scattered each other
we're not a said the San Francisco ones
are pretty tight on the sunny day I want
something tight as well what's special
about this is that everyone has their
I'll expose them even if they live
pretty close to one or more lies inside
location is very very local it's very
area specific so I'm very different from
the Sunnyvale person who's ready once
and for all in focus or Rover
turning our location on scultures even
if we love one another it's kind of cool
wow great is that you can actually see
what are the species we're driving is
some of the numbers we see the leaves
vocation I thought some fun examples are
the san francisco exposure is an action
you pick up sludge bacteria is one of
the wings things be more specific for
the san francisco clothes or also for
the others on if you ever walk down
Market Street in San Francisco and you
can probably understand why this result
out so anyway the point is you can map
out specific warnings in specific
location we do think of sequences very
similar pathogens will come back to this
in a minute
we also have strong he's little
components its findings of species it
shows he's an effect so the greening
runs a little spring abundant organisms
though light blue or summer or fall
darkest blue or winner so again hundreds
many of these we known already a lot of
new for example we shown over on the
right if he pine at some people known
already like spring or summer this
turkey tail mushroom is more like eight
for early winter and so on as well you
can actually correlate new powers do a
lot of fun I mention that you actually
can find they're very very rare looks
very similar the pathogens then River
and column but there are samples and
slower group screenings further well we
do find seasonal effects of chemicals is
the chemical results we find 10 all
kinds of chemical from the samples there
are plastic components in every sample
of pesticides use price Imaging's
their abundance depends on location
they're very influenced by location and
you can even pick up some things that
correlate with rain you probably know
you can smell when it's gonna rain it's
because well air pressure drops in this
compound just min comes out around and
your actual smell until finals Noreen it
turns out when it rains plastic
happiness only washing to the grounds we
won't breathing in his life maybe all
speaking if it's about maybe drinking
them body Saint comes off you when the
air pressure drops us down on the ground
it's not so exciting then so these are
things you can learn from these things
well the coolest results we have is
shown here this is things that we wanted
to correlate biologicals and chemicals
and what we found is this nasty chemical
at the bottom form pyridine it's often
found in paints and other things it
inversely correlates with fun job so
where every up here game which is look
over that light blue while emboss them
was a lot of tyranny where in that
sample and it cleared low fungi and uses
a perfect game for correlation so what
we think then is the pure names probably
inhibiting fungal growth and so if
you're allergic to mold decide to make
beautiful maybe you want your house
plenty with a clear to paint the fungal
mom standoff I know maybe I'll buy
cancer but least you know yes black mold
allergies that your name so this is kind
of something decide on their own it's
both but you want to use the summary of
all this is that we can actually build
personal exposure loud so this is mine
everybody not somebody isn't different
round a lot of human associated
sequences in here let's not surprising
along this breed and in Salem and we
subjected those action million but you
can tell what people have I am getting
really big nails shell from the sampling
the plant and so forth so you know these
are in fact what you can do you build
people's course more clouds but I think
it's gonna be powerful about all this is
that all of these data you can collect
in your smartphone now we're building
Perth my dashboard so we can actually
start setting up exactly what do we
constrain the gain in you can see it
like a wearables or getting like bomb
another data so you can see exactly how
your heart from dimensions tracking and
see it in real time then follow you over
these times and see what's going on sure
this will
position so they can better understand
what's going on with you and lastly this
is how iced tea was holding rolling out
the future that on people this is the
Mike Snyder world I see people getting
their due months to 24 burn together all
mixed we're more measurement thank you
for our people carefully to see what go
risk for within science magazines and
being able to better intervene so last
night we want to credit I have an
amazing lab
Ronnie makes me take the fried and
others on this Gribble's and challenge
us
well George Weinstock fantastic library
my crime analysis change McLaughlin all
technical side expose your work is
domain strong group tonight without and
are singin John then we getting
supported by the NH and that's been
terrific for making this possible so
thanks again very much for having me
here if you have any questions I'm happy
to answer one more mom thanks again
thank you dr. Schneider for that
informative presentation
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible as a final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us we'll see you
next time goodbye